so in the winter of 2012 I went to visit
my grandmother's house in South India a
place by the way where the mosquitoes
have a special taste for the blood of
the american-born no joke when I was
there I got an unexpected gift it was
this antique instrument made more than a
century ago hand-carved from a rare wood
inlaid with pearls and with dozens of
metal strings it's a family heirloom
a link between my past the country where
my parents were born and the future the
unknown places I'll take it I didn't
actually realize it at the time I got it
but it would later become a powerful
metaphor for my work we all know the
saying there's no time like the present
but nowadays it can feel like there's no
time but the present
what's immediate and ephemeral seems to
dominate our lives our economy and our
politics you know it's so easy to get
caught up in the number of steps we took
today or the latest tweet from a
high-profile figure it's easy for
businesses to get caught up in making
immediate profits and neglects what's
good for future invention and it's far
too easy for governments to stand by
while fisheries and farmland are
depleted instead of conserve to feed
future generations I have a feeling that
at this rate it's going to be hard for
our generation to be remembered as good
ancestors if you think about it our
species evolved to think ahead to chart
the Stars dream of the afterlife so
seeds for later harvest some scientists
all this superpower that we have mental
time travel and it's responsible for
pretty much everything we call human
civilization from farming to the Magna
Carta to the internet all first conjured
in the minds of humans but let's get
real if we look around us today we don't
exactly seem to be using this superpower
quite enough and that begs the question
why not what's wrong is how our
communities businesses and institutions
are designed they're designed in a way
that's impairing our foresight I want to
talk to you about the three key mistakes
that I think we're making the first
mistake is what we measure when we look
at the quarterly profits of a company or
its near-term stock price that's often
not a great measure of whether that
company is going to grow its market
share or be inventive in the long run
when we glue ourselves to the test
scores that kids big bring back from
school that's not necessarily what's
great for those kids learning and
curiosity in the long run we're not
measuring what really matters in the
future the second mistake we're making
that impairs our foresight is what we
reward when we celebrate a political
leader or a business leader for the
disaster she just cleaned up or the
announcement she just made
we're not motivating that leader to
invest in preventing those disasters in
the first place or to put down payments
on the future by protecting communities
from floods or fighting inequality or
investing in research and education the
third mistake that impairs our foresight
is what we fail to imagine now when we
do think about the future we tend to
focus on predicting exactly what's next
whether we're using horoscopes or
algorithms to do that but we spent a lot
less time imagining all the
possibilities the future holds
the Ebola outbreak emerged in 2014 in
West Africa
public health officials around the world
had early warning signs and predictive
tools that showed how that outbreak
might spread but they failed to fathom
that it would and they failed to act in
time to intervene and the epidemic grew
to kill more than 11,000 people when
people with lots of resources and good
forecasts don't prepare for deadly
hurricanes they're often failing to
imagine how dangerous they can be now
none of these mistakes that I've
described as dismal as they might sound
are inevitable in fact they're all
avoidable what we need to make better
decisions about the future are tools
that can aid our foresight tools that
can help us think ahead think of these
as something like the telescopes that
ship captains of your used when they
scanned the horizon only instead of for
looking across distance and the ocean
these tools are for looking across time
to the future I want to share with you a
few of the tools that I've found in my
research that I think can help us with
foresight the first tool I want to share
with you I think of as making the long
game pay now this is Wes Jackson a
farmer I spent some time with in Kansas
and Jackson knows that the way that most
crops are grown around the world today
is stripping the earth of the fertile
topsoil we need to feed future
generations he got together with a group
of scientists and they bred perennial
grain crops which have deep roots that
anchor the fertile topsoil of a farm
preventing erosion and protecting future
harvests but they also knew that in
order to get farmers to grow these crops
in the short run they needed to boost
the annual yields of the crops and find
companies willing to make cereal and
beer using the grains so that farmers
could reap profits today by doing what's
good for tomorrow and this is a tried
and trued strategy in fact it was used
by George Washington Carver
in the south of the United States after
the Civil War in the early 20th century
a lot of people have probably heard of
Carver's 300 uses for the peanuts the
products and recipes that he and came up
with that made the peanuts so popular
but not everyone knows why Carver did
that he was trying to help poorer
Alabama sharecroppers whose cotton
yields were declining and he knew that
planting peanuts in their fields would
replenish those soils so that their
cotton yields would be better a few
years later but he also knew it needed
to be lucrative for them in the short
run all right so let's talk about
another tool for some foresight this one
I like to think of as keeping the memory
of the past alive to help us imagine the
future so I went to Fukushima Japan on
the sixth anniversary of the nuclear
reactor disaster there that followed the
Tohoku earthquake and tsunami of 2011
when I was there I learned about the own
Ogawa a nuclear power station which was
even closer to the epicenter of that
earthquake than the infamous Fukushima
Daiichi that we all know about in
Onagawa people in the city actually fled
to the nuclear power plant as a place of
refuge it was that safe
it was spared by the tsunamis it was the
foresight of just one engineer yana suka
here i that made that happen in the
1960s he fought to build that power
plant farther back from the coast at
higher elevation and with a higher
seawall
he knew the story of his hometown shrine
which had flooded in the year 869 after
a tsunami
it was his knowledge of history that
allowed him to imagine what others could
not okay one more tool of foresight this
one I think of as creating shared
heirlooms these are lobster fishermen on
the Pacific coast of Mexico and they're
the ones who taught me this they have
protected their lobster harvest there
for nearly a century and they've done
that by treating it as a shared resource
that they're passing on to their
collective
children and grandchildren they
carefully measure what they catch so
that they're not taking the breeding
lobster out of the ocean across North
America there are more than 30 fisheries
that are doing something vaguely similar
to this they're creating long term
stakes in the fisheries known as cat
shares which get fishermen to be
motivated not just in taking whatever
they can from the ocean today but in its
long-term survival now there are many
many more tools of foresight I would
love to share with you and they come
from all kinds of places investment
firms that look beyond near-term stock
prices states that have freed their
elections from the immediate interests
of campaign finance years and we're
going to need to marshal as many of
these tools as we can if we want to
rethink what we measure change what we
reward and be brave enough to imagine
what lies ahead not all this is going to
be easy as you can imagine some of these
tools we can pick up in our own lives
some we're going to need to do in
businesses or in communities and some we
need to do as a society the future is
worth this effort my own inspiration to
keep up this effort is the instrument I
shared with you it's called a bill rubra
and it was custom made for my great
grandfather he was a well-known music
and art critic in India in the early
20th century
my great grandfather had the foresight
to protect this instrument at a time
when my great grandmother was pawning
off all their belongings but that's
another story
he protected it by giving it to the next
generation by giving it to my
grandmother and she gave it to me
when I first heard the sound of this
instrument it haunted me it felt like
hearing a wanderer in the Himalayan fog
it felt like hearing a voice from the
past
[Music]
that's my friend Simran Singh playing
the bill Reba when I play it it sounds
like a cat's dying somewhere so you're
welcome this instrument is in my home
today but it doesn't actually belong to
me it's my role to shepherd it in time
and that feels more meaningful to me
than just owning it for today
this instrument positions me as both the
descendant and an ancestor it makes me
feel part of a story bigger than my own
and this I believe is the single most
powerful way we can reclaim foresight by
seeing ourselves as the good ancestors
we long to be ancestors not just to our
own children but to all humanity
whatever your heirloom is however big or
small protect it and know that its music
can resonate for generations thank you
[Applause]
[Music]